I'm now going to do one of my favorite
reactions it's not very spectacular but
I think it's very satisfying it's the
reaction between hydrogen peroxide and
potassium permanganate let's begin with
Bigwater so I'll add some potassium
permanganate which has gives it a nice
pinkish purple color you've probably
heard me saying already that my
grandfather used to put permanganate in
his goldfish tank so the fish would swim
round in purple water didn't seem to do
them any harm we now add a little bit of
sulfuric acid the acid doesn't change
the color at all so you can see now
we've got some nice purple potassium
permanganate and now we will take some
hydrogen peroxide Sam had the big bottle
that she needs to be used up and we'll
add it and see if we can see anything
happening
so what carefully
I think it may be flat try another
bottle get some of my own hydrogen
peroxide instead yes well hydrogen
peroxide can decompose into oxygen and
water and if you keep it too long it
goes off so I get some more so we got
some more there isn't very much of it
but perhaps this will be enough
I'm not very impressed to you the best
thing outside hydrogen peroxide has the
formula h2o - and it has quite a strange
structure this is a model that I use for
the students I'm sorry the atoms are all
the same color but you imagine this one
and that one the ones I'm holding with
my hands are hydrogen's and the two
black ones are oxygen and the important
thing is you can see is quite short
hydrogen oxygen bombs and a very long
oxygen oxygen bond which is weak and
breaks very easily which is what makes
hydrogen peroxide so reactive it also
has this rather strange set structure
that this bond is it right angles to
that one if I hold it up this one is
horizontal and that one is vertical and
so it has a rather strange symmetrical
structure I once hit myself very hard on
the nose while demonstrating this in the
lecture so you have a long oxygen oxygen
bond that makes hydrogen peroxide very
reactive pure hydrogen peroxide will set
fire to almost oral organic matter so if
you put it on a piece of cloth washed it
goes up in flames so normally people use
hydrogen peroxide is a dilute solution
and here you can see we have one
solution which is called 40 volume which
means one liter of liquid gives 40
liters of oxygen gas if it decomposes
and this example here which you can see
has more aggressive warnings that day
more dangerous this is a hundred volume
and so the hydrogen peroxide that you
buy in the chemists for bleaching your
hair is much weaker it may
be 5 or 10 volume so this is 110 times
stronger
you wouldn't bleach your hair with this
might go up in smoke trying again this
time I hope a bit better
I put warm water in here so the reaction
may be faster and I'll put in most of
the acid as well then a bit of
permanganate and now we've got enough
peroxide still left you can see it's
decolorizing straight away that's pretty
cool so what's happened now I didn't
wash the thing out properly and we had
some peroxide left and now it's reacting
faster than we can add the permanganate
so this is actually much better than I
intended because I was going to make it
purple and make it go clear and here you
can see I'm pouring in the purple
solution and it's disappearing
that's Bria and you can see it's
releasing oxygen from the hydrogen
peroxide so when it hits the surface the
manganese which is bound to oxygen in
permanganate reacts and loses its oxygen
and forms manganese ions manganese 2
plus for those of your chemists which
are completely colorless so it goes from
this very intensely colored salt to the
colorless one so it's like magic isn't
it you have to remember this trick yes
lovely this wasn't what you wanted to
show us no but it's even better they now
have to explain to the technicians where
I've used the whole bottle of
permanganate solution
you